what was the other other half sure Levi
writes mark is there anything you can
add in terms of a director bringing a
great scene to life okay I mean first of
all everything Michaels saying as far as
I can write on in terms of creating that
scene and all which I appreciate I do
appreciate all the LD elements about
about the objectives and about the
obstacles and about the subject all of
that is necessary for a good scene now
my job is a director a director's job
now to bring it to life first while
we're bringing in actors which is only
going to make it more complex and
confusing but the the first thing is
sort of going to look back a little bit
what Michaels saying is for the director
to look at this scene now and it's just
assuming the writers not there or
whatever just looking at the scene and
starting to understand a lot about the
scene in terms of what Michael was just
talking about in other words okay I have
these scene these two or three
characters what do what does each
character want do I know what each
character wants do I know what the
obstacles are do I know what's in the
way of him or her achieving what do they
wanted to say do they achieve what they
wanted to say do they think they have
achieved it and maybe they haven't have
they achieved it and maybe they don't
realize they have in other words what
even the looking at the character do
they have an idea of how the character
thought he might go about trying to
achieve what he wants in other words
what was his intention how you know what
was his plan did he have a plan is he
going on just all of these things that
are going on inside the character then
going down deeper and into the scene
again with it before working with actors
subtextual II what is going on between
these characters which good is going on
in every single scene every single
moment there is a deep rich subtext of
what the characters are not saying some
of the dialogue you talked about that is
that horrible dialogue on the nose
well that's not being said okay now I'm
looking to seeing it's not there that
right it didn't give me that do I know
can I feel can I sense do I have any
idea of what's really going on inside
these characters a lot of what I talk
about is every character and every scene
has two objectives I mean it has way
more than two but there are two main one
objective is the objective the character
would state this is what I want I want
to
Vince her that we should go on this
vacation that's the scene great what's
really gone now there's a private
objective what am I really doing what's
really driving me is it my control over
her or my dominance of it you know what
what it what is the really deeper
objective am I trying to prove her to
her that I'm a good leader I don't know
whatever it is which is not written in
the scene can I sense that for every
single character in the scene then
there's another part of the scene this
again before working with the actors to
me every scene has everything I don't
care how small the scene is every scene
has what I call a core moment there's a
moment in the scene there's a little
moment usually come this is all very
almost very similar to your structure
for the whole story it usually comes
about almost at the end of the scene
three quarters a little the end there's
a moment and sometimes it's the briefest
moment it could be a recognition it
could be a line it could be some
somebodies which is really the primary
reason why this scene is in the movie
now the characters have to go through
this whole scene and pursue these
objectives and up against these
obstacles and then go and then they're
going to hit this core moment where
either
we'll just take say there were two
characters the characters realize
something understand something here's
something sense something there's a
shift there's a slight change this is
part of the arc and the transformation
of the character or I the audience sense
something see something something is
going to shift in me that I realize
about the character that the character
always knew and now it's revealed or
it's revealed from one character to
another in other words there's something
that by the end of this scene everything
has changed and it could happen in a
brief moment a real brief moment so you
know so I work with directors I said
identify what that core moment is what
you think that is because I say as
you're directing it you're aiming for
that you're aiming for that moment to
happen between the characters in between
the characters and the audience then you
bring in the actors now we'll bring in
the actor
we're adding the elements of how to
direct the scene then you go back to
like we were talking about earlier
building the character interrogating the
character igniting the character and
then to make the scene work how did you
think about one thing I have this
character this man he's going to go in
he's got try to convince his wife to
what go on a vacation or something
simple like that what state of mind
emotional mental spiritual physical
whatever do I want to send this
character into the scene
how does he start and what is his
intention his objective of the beginning
actually forget for the moment how the
scene turns out forget it because the
character doesn't know how this scene is
going to turn out so you got if you want
an authentic character you got to figure
out how to send him in and allow the
character as we're rehearsing allow the
character ignited in a certain way to go
in and literally not play the scene but
run into the scene and be surprised by
what he says and what the other person
says not be planned I say this you say
that I said that's the plan seen an
authentic scene is I'm surprised
surprised by what you said I'm even
surprised by what I said
in other words that's that's the
authenticity and still I'm designing it
to hit that core moment
you